hello and welcome back to PlayStation
granade 10 years ago burnout paradise
hit the ps3 and the 360 to rave reviews
but it's never received the second
outing that it truly deserved so much
time has now passed that many new
players have never heard of Paradise
City but oh my word
the remaster is absolutely perfect and
I'll happily tell you why the awesome
speed and crash is the hidden game mode
the compelling online it's all here so
here are 7 ways burnout paradise
remastered is the perfect arcade racer
open worlds in racing games began with
Paradise City and the spectacle of
winding roads in the mountains and
densely populated intersections of the
city areas driving through each of those
junctions reveals an assignment if that
mission is not for you simply keep on
driving you are never forced to complete
any task in burnout paradise minder that
there are a hundred and twenty events
ready to launch from a hundred and
twenty different traffic signals around
the city so you're never more than a
moment from some burnout action should
you decide to take part in a race or any
other event for that matter slow down
and hold l2 and r2 at the lights the
core game modes are racing from A to B
against seven other drivers but going A
to B is only the starting point as you
must decide the best route to take it's
unbelievably easy to take a wrong turn
and turn a certain first-place finish
into a last-place mess up if you're not
one to go racing then go on time stunt
challenges instead flipping and smashing
your way around the city or what about
trying road rage in which you smash
other cars into walls and oncoming
vehicles there's even a marked man race
modifier where you are forced to reach a
destination without your car being
destroyed by other aggressive vehicles
victories in any or all of these
disciplines tie into the progression
system and the hunt for the sacred
burnouts license and when that's
achieved the real tests begin scratching
the surface of burnout paradise
remastered reveal so much more for
gamers to get their teeth into as new
vehicles are unlocked they aren't simply
placed in your garage like every other
racing game you've played know instead
that vehicle can be found racing
around the streets anywhere in the open
world if you really want that vehicle
you must take it down this small update
to accessing vehicles keeps you on your
toes as any second that roadster you've
always wanted
suddenly races by on into the distance
time to shut it down the Carson and
Bennett Grand Marais has been delivered
to your junkyard
now it's a wreck and it's yours going
back to the junkyard and taking that
wreckage to a trusty mechanic and now
the car is completely ready to go on the
open road speaking of cars there are 75
to unlock smash repair and drive but
that's only the beginning burnout
paradise remastered includes all eight
Adams from the original game this means
there are motorbikes remote-control cars
I'm not lying
Beach boogies and even the Ghostbusters
ride gets an outing in Paradise the
customization isn't fantastic but colors
and paint finishes can be selected and
can even be changed on the fly by going
through spray shops it can even be done
mid race every vehicle you unlock really
does feel like a reward and the stats
help us decide how the cash should be
used
is it a build for speed for stumps offer
taking down other players oh and look
the freakin DeLorean from Back to the
Future is here ea just take my money but
wait there's even more to uncover in
Paradise City burnouts approach to
collectibles is one of the most
addicting I've ever experienced spread
across the entire world are these yellow
do not enter signs which reveal hidden
shortcuts to give you the edge in races
suddenly a winding road can be
completely missed by searching for
hidden routes around the location the
collectibles don't end there as
billboards can be smashed and super
jumps can be found that resemble the
photo jumps back in the Tony Hawk's days
on top of this is our ability to rule
roads around the city and countryside
every single road has a time trial and a
crash mode to plunder every time you
drive across a road the time is recorded
even if you don't want to race at that
point a small 8 second road are a three
minute Road your time is always stored
and if you manage to beat the record the
street sign becomes silver to show you
that you hold a record here to make the
sign go golden you must take part in the
iconic crash mode
is famous for here in Paradise City this
is called Showtime Showtime is all about
causing as much damage as possible and
maneuvering your wreck into other cars
and buses for multipliers to start
Showtime press l1 and r1 together and
begin the carnage you can spend hundreds
of hours in paradise remastered
completely ignoring the main game and
instead owning every street you drive on
once you hold both speed and crush
record the street sign becomes gold
until somebody beats you of course we
must pause for a moment and take note of
the sublime soundtrack included in the
game it's such a focus that the our one
button is dedicated to switching tracks
if the current song doesn't suit your
mood mammoth bands like Faith No More
and Guns and Roses head up the
soundtrack and previous tombs in the
burnout series also make a return it may
be a soundtrack better suited to ten
years ago but for someone who played the
original this will make the feeling of
belonging and those nostalgia moments
come hopping back going online and
there's even more to uncover in burnout
paradise remastered by pressing right on
the d-pad we can hop onto online play
and race alongside seven randoms or
seven friends as it's an open world
there's nothing stopping anyone from
driving away and doing their own thing
but by teaming up there are further
challenges to perform in teams of two
three and so on and so forth for example
you and a buddy can race head-on over a
jump and crash midair to unlock one
challenge these are free roam or free
burn challenges and there's 352 master
plus another seventy time challenges ten
motorbike trials and ten island
challenges too from all the DLC we get
for free this game will take over your
life it's so packed with things to do so
in conclusion is burnout paradise
remastered worth returning to in my mind
oh my god yes it is of course there are
some shortcomings due to the era the
original was made controls and heads-up
displays have changed in particularly in
the last few years but in the last 10
years of searching for an arcade
open-world game I have never found one
that better to burn out paradise the
remaster is just as great as the
original with shiny new graphics
improved responsive 'ti and frame rates
and soup
online stability if this paved the way
for burnout paradise - then I'll be
absolutely ecstatic what do you think
about returning to games ten years later
and will you be venturing back into
paradise or maybe it's your first time
hearing about this title I'd love to
know your thoughts I'm Adam from
PlayStation granade and I'm going back
to practice my parallel parking it's
been a pleasure I'll see you next time
power parking the only way to park in
Paradise Hey Hey You you I don't like a
girlfriend no oh my god I'm singing
opera Levine what have you done to me
burn up